these latest figures confirm what we've
been seeing across the country recently
and explain why things
are looking so bad eighteen thousand
three hundred and seventy-one
positive cases of covid19 were recorded
in england between the third and 9th of
september
that's an increase of 167
compared with the end of august it's the
highest weekly number since the
country's test and trace system
was launched in may this graph shows the
percentage of tests that have come back
positive and gives a clear indication
that things
seem to be going backwards it started at
the beginning of june at just
under two and a half percent this fell
to its lowest level in mid-july
at just over one percent but here at the
beginning of september
you can see a significant increase in
the latest results
with more than three percent of tests
coming back
positive again this is the highest it's
been since test and trace was launched
but this graph shows how the system is
struggling
to get results processed quickly in june
boris johnson promised that all results
would be back within 24 hours
for in-person tests and 48 hours
for postal ones as you can see all of
them
are taking longer with just a third of
in-person tests
now coming back within 24 hours all of
these lines
represent the different ways you can get
a test such as home test kits
regional testing sites mobile testing
units and
satellite test centers and you can see
that the amount of people
getting their results within the
government target
is at its lowest ever point
if you look at home test kits for
example it got to nearly 80
in mid july but today's figures show
that less than 10 percent of results
came back within the government target
baroness dido harding the head of the
test and trace program
was called to answer mp's questions
about the lack of capacity in the system
she says the system is not failing but
it didn't predict the demand
because the modeling had got it wrong
we've been running some surveys outside
of our testing sites so after you've
registered and you've
then turned up at the testing site and
we've asked people
whether or not they do actually have
symptoms and we surveyed so if i give
you the details 24
000 people at 25 regional and local
testing sites between the 1st and the
4th of september
the secretary of state referred to this
earlier today and this data will be
published online
27 of people said they were there
because they'd been in contact with
someone
who had tested positive but they didn't
have symptoms themselves
now this isn't the first time the blame
has been shifted on
to the modeling but ultimately the
responsibility must lie with the
government
the warning signs were there